is there a philosophical pragmatic way
to start talking about the pillars of
christianity what are the defining
things that make
christianity to you
and and broadly speaking uh to those
that follow the religion
you know in a way what we're doing so
far is is a necessary propaguetic
because we're talking about god
um
what makes christianity distinctive of
course is the claim of the incarnation
so we come up out of judaism we come up
out of this great monotheistic tradition
and you know the bible itself and all
the great commentators within judaism i
think would agree with this basic
theistic stuff that i've been talking
about taking moses maimonides for
example
now what makes christianity distinct
this
supremely weird claim
that god
becomes one of us god becomes a creature
but without ceasing to be god and
without overwhelming the integrity of
the creature he becomes
what we see in the burning bush that
principle which obtains across the board
so the closer god comes to me the more
radiant i become right
but take that now to the nth degree
would be what we mean by the incarnation
the incarnation of the son of god
becoming a creature
in such a way as to make humanity
radiant and beautiful
that's the pillar of christianity it's
the incarnation you know um
and what follows from that is the
redemption of of all of reality so not
just of human beings but in becoming
a creature god
divinizes the world
you know the greek fathers always said
god became human that humans might
become god
and that's a good way to sum up i think
the essence of christianity
why is this such an important thing so
it's a distinctive thing yeah but why is
it so important philosophically
to what it means to be a christian like
what impact did that have on our world
on human civilization on human nature on
our morals of why live
what to live for the meaning of it all
like why is incarnation so important
well i think it's it's massively
important because it's it's the
divinization principle that god wants to
demonize his creation and and sort of in
this concentrated point of jesus of
nazareth but then we talk about the
mystical body of jesus so that goes
right back to paul
as we're grafted on to christ we talk
about that as the church we become
like cells and molecules in an organism
that's the church it's not an
organization that's a that's a
deformation of ecclesiology the church
is this organism that begins with jesus
and then he's drawing
all of humanity but ultimately all of
nature all of all of creation to himself
when the son of man is lifted up he will
draw all things to himself that idea of
the gathering in of a of a scattered
creation
so in that way it's at the heart of it
then there's all kinds of things if god
becomes human that means there's a
dignity to humanity which goes beyond
anything any humanist of any stripe has
ever said right ancient
medieval modern
contemporary christianity is the
greatest humanism imaginable
god became one of us in order to
demonize us
the the goal of my life is not just to
be a good person not just to be
you know materially successful not just
to be
a member of society the goal of my life
is to become a participant in the divine
nature and so there i don't think there
is a humanism greater than that even
conceivably so that's where i think
humanism
is profoundly influenced by the
incarnation
uh and just our notion of god as
non-competitive to us that's so
important because i think in so many
systems from mythology onward you have
these competitive understandings of god
when jesus says to his disciples the
night before he dies i no longer call
you servants but friends it's an
extraordinary moment because every god
right who's ever been served well that's
that's the best we can hope for is
the servant of god
you know i i try to obey you lord i'll
try to do what you want but when jesus
says i no longer call you servants or
slaves you would have said in the greek
there you know um but friends
i don't know
i can't imagine anything greater than
that becoming god's friend
you